вітаємо шановні учасники та учасниці
нашого заходу впевнена що з нами зараз
багато освітян і зокрема вчителів
Дякуємо що доєдналися і Дякуємо тим хто
буде дивитися запис цього етеру пізніше
учителі сьогодні виявляють небияку
стійкість та адаптивність онлайн офлайн
змішане навчання викладання в укритті це
типові виклики під п час війни І
сьогодні ми пропонуємо вам познайомитися
з можливостями для вчителів які можуть
підвищити витривалість та додати наснаги
під час цього заходу доповідачі
розкриють для вас як саме спільноти
освітян можуть допомогти удосконалити
педагогічні практики та вирішити цифрові
питання безпеки та благополуччя на
прикладах спікери розкриють питання
використання цифрових технологій та
психосоціальної підтримки вчителів під
час війни криз та у часи
невизначеності ми будемо раді вашим
коментарям та запитанням під цією
трансляцією відповіді на них будуть
надані безпосередньо під питаннями або в
окремому пості в спільноті сучасних
учителів тому не обмежуйте себе для нас
дуже важливо отримати зворотній зв'язок
від вас Тож розпочинаємо наш захід і
першому надаю слово заступнику міністра
освіти і науки України з питань
цифрового розвитку цифрових
трансформацій і цифровізації пану дмитру
завгородньому пан Дмитро вам слово
Доброго дня Дякую вам ну перш за все
хочу
подякувати нашим партнерам компа команді
Юнеско і команді цього проекту цифровий
вчитель е за надзвичайну роботу за
зроблений курс за ті Заходи які ви
проводите і впевнений що вже десятки
тисяч вчителів задоволені і вдячні за цю
Прекрасну
роботу насправді сьогодні хотів сказати
про те що протягом останніх декількох
років ми разом дуже багато зробили з
нашими партнерами з вчителями закладами
освіти іноземними між родними
організаціями урядами і колегами з
Міністерства освіти і наших державних
установ і завдяки цьому маємо вже багато
різноманітних цифрових платформ
застосунків всеукраїнську школу онлайн
діє цифрова освіта застосунок вивчаю Не
чекаю крім цього дуже багато процесів
трансформувалося в цифровий вигляд І
продовжують трансформуватися ми перевели
в цифровий вигляд іспити з національно
мультипредметного тесту а також в
подальші іспити на магістратуру далі
цього буде ставати дедалі більше і на
наступний рік у нас також багато планів
про переведення в цифровий вигляд
процесів зарахування учнів переведення і
багато чого іншого контенту цифрового
з'являється дедалі більше і на державних
і на приватних платформах тож вчителям
вже є є чим користуватися крім цього
протягом цих років Ми дуже багато часу
Ляли тому щоб навчити користуватися цими
продуктами і вважаємо що цифрові навички
є надзвичайно важливими тому що просто
існування цих платформ не забезпечує
трансформації освітнього процесу і сотні
тисяч вчителів пройшли ті чи інші курси
з цифрової грамотності або користування
якимись конкретними інструментами які
були їм запропоновані крім цього дуже
важливо розуміти що цей цифровий світ
його і це ринок цифрових застосунків
розвивається дуже швидко набагато швидше
ніж трансформація будь-яких величезних
систем як системи освіти тому кожного
місяця з'являються нові можливості нові
інструменти новий цифровий контент нові
застосунки нові платформи і
орієнтуватися в цьому всьому і вчителям
і нам достатньо важко тому ми вирішили
потрошки переходити на наступний рівень
підтримки вже цих цифрових навичок не
лише створюючи нові курси а й створюючи
і допомагаючи нашим вчителям створювати
спільноти для обміну досвідом оскільки
Ми віримо що вже ті вчителі ті сотні
тисяч людей які вже навчилися пройшли ті
чи інші курси застосували продукти які
їм більше
сподобалися мають можливість
обмінюватися досвідом мають можливість е
поділитися з своїми колегами
тими практиками які вважають ефективними
і саме в цьому постійному обміні
досвідом Мені здається полягає подальший
розвиток таких цифрових навичок тому
сподіваюся що сьогоднішня робота буде
для всіх корисною та цікавою Дуже дякую
вам за
можливість поділитися своїми думками
стосовно цього Дякую
щиро дякую пане Дмитре за те що
привітали учасників цього заходу і
учасниць за те що трохи
перевідкрили завісу про що ж ми сьогодні
будемо говорити а власне Ми сьогодні
більш детально розкажемо про курс
цифровий вчитель та про спільноту яка
допомагає його підтримувати а проте
перед цим я хочу надати слово начальнику
відділу взаємодії з місцевими органами
влади директорату шкільної освіти
Міністерства освіти і науки України
пані
іні кільдерові і вона окреслить питання
організації навчального процесу під час
війни та саме вже роль спільнот
практиків в реалізації потреб сучасної
освіти пані Іно вам
слово Добрий день шановні колеги Дякую
за можливість долучитися до
сьогоднішнього
заходу Бажаю всім продуктивної праці
сьогодні гарного настрою і обміну
цікавим досвідом Отже трішки про те як
побудована система освіти у період війни
в умовах воєнного стану безумовно одним
із пріоритетних завдань держави є
збереження життя та здоров'я її
громадян особливо дітей та забезпечення
їх безперервного доступу до
освіти На жаль освітня статистика на
сьогодні
невтішна на першому слайді
представлені дані що ми
маємо в межах освітньої
інфраструктури Отже на сьогодні повністю
зруйновано
381 заклад пошкоджено
3436 закладів освіти у тому числі
зруйновано 212 закладів загальної
середньої
освіти
681 школа пошкоджена 920 закладів
перебувають на тимчасово окупованих
територіях України тому як і минулого
навчального року не всі діти можуть
долучитися до навчального процесу саме в
стінах закладу освіти тому одним із
найбільших викликів для навчання під час
воєнного стану є впровадження
різноманітних форм навчання цього року
як і минулого за рішеннями
військово-цивільних адміністрацій
відповідно до ситуації в кожному регіоні
залежно від безпекової ситуації були
прийняті рішення щодо проведення
освітнього процесу за різними формами на
наступному слайді будь ласка ми можемо
побачити освітню статистику щодо
організації форм навчання в закладах
освіти Отже на сьогодні
функціонують
12603 заклади освіти із них заочною
формою функціонують
7262 заклади освіти дистанційно
241 заклад І у змішаному режимі
закладів понад 225 000 учнів є
внутрішньо переміщеними особами
68356 учнів із тимчасово окупованих
територій здобувають освіту в інших
регіонах України понад 390 000 учнів і
понад 7 000 вчителів перебувають досі за
кордоном Отже представлена статистика
свідчить про те
що система освіти має адаптуватися до
сучасних викликів і реагувати на них
належним чином будь ласка наступний
слайд Якщо говорити про категорією дітей
які досі перебувають за кордоном то ми
можемо побачити що для них форма
організації освітнього
процесу представлена за різними
форматами за дистанційною формою
навчання понад 243 000 дітей навчається
за сімейною формою навчання понад 100
000 за екстна ною формою
навчання понад 40 000 осіб і у
дистанційних класах які були створені на
сьогодні міністерством освіти разом із
місцевими органами управління у сфері
освіти навчаються понад 2000
осіб Отже презентацію можна завершити
Дякую Отже міністерством освіти на
сьогодні вживається низка заходів для
того щоб забезпечити право на добуття
освіти всіх категорій дітей які на
сьогодні ми маємо В умовах воєнного
стану перш за все
створюються умови для безпечного
навчання в закладах освіти у минулому
році урядом було передбачено 1 млрди
гривень на облаштування безпечних умов у
закладах освіти в школах тобто заклади
могли обла лаштувати нові
укриття могли провести капітальні
ремонти реконструкції вже тих укриттів
які були в школах цього року урядом
збільшено субвенцію на укриття і ми
маємо вже 2, по млрди гривень які будуть
спрямовані на будівництво ремонти та
облаштування
укриттів для тих дітей які на сьогодні
перебувають за кордоном теж багато
зроблено ее для них підібрано саме ті
варіанти здобуття української освіти е
Які є найбільш прийнятними для кожного е
кожна родина може обрати те як дитина
далі буде продовжувати своє навчання е в
межах української системи освіти якщо е
говорити про цих дітей що перебувають за
кордоном то вони на сьогодні можуть
Навчатися або виключно в межах країни
перебування або паралельно здобувати
освіту
е в закладі країни перебування та в
закладі українському за однією з форм
навчання також це може бути державний
ліцей міжнародна українська
школа водночас Якщо це не суперечить
законодавству країни перебування такі
діти можуть навчатися тільки в закладі
освіти України для зменшення
навантаження на таких дітей
е які перебувають за кордоном мон
цьогоріч запроваджено дистанційне
вивчення предметів українознавчого
компонента в окремо визначених школах в
кожному регіоні України в місті Києві
було визначено по п'ять шкіл які
забезпечували б такий формат навчання
такий перелік шкіл оприлюднений на
офіційному сайті монс і охочі можуть
ознайомитися з ним і знайти той заклад
де дитина може продовжити навчання в
межах України
попри систематичну та злагоджену роботу
в умовах війни органів влади місцевого
самоврядування керівників закладів
освіти педагогів усе частіше На жаль ми
вживаємо термін освітні втрати яких
зазнали на сьогодні українські діти їхнє
подолання звісно і є тим пріоритетом
української
освіти з яким ми маємо працювати надалі
десятки тисяч вчителі в Україні
стикаються із проблемами організації
якісного дистанційного навчання тому у
контексті сьогодення цифровізація освіти
стала важливим інструментом в реалізації
права на освіту вимушено переміщених
дітей у тому числі тих хто знаходиться
за кордоном і продовжує успішно
навчатися в українських школах
дистанційно тому цифровізація освіти є
надзвичайно важливою вона допомагає
підвищувати стійкість в умовах війни
школи адаптуються оперативно змінюють
формати навчання відповідно до ситуації
Ну а звісно Міністерство як центральний
орган виконавчої влади разом із
партнерами докладає максимальнону зусиль
для забезпечення відповідної
інфраструктури та можливостей для цього
так наприклад у
2223 роках було створено Кілька десятків
освітніх центрів в Київській
Чернігівській Миколаїв областях які
стали своєрідною швидкою освітньою
допомогою для надання дітям у громадах
які постраждали від війни доступу до
навчання адже на сьогодні межі класної
кімнати не можна вимірювати тільки
стінами уміння працювати з цифровими
інструментами критично мислити
аналізувати медіатексти - це об'єктивна
потреба проектна діяльність на сьогодні
- це усвідомлення комплексності завдань
які стоять перед освітою
водночас саме вчитель є ключовою фігурою
освітнього процесу від початку воєнної
агресії саме педагоги надійно тримали
освітній фронт адаптуючись до нових
викликів
щохвилини на сучасному етапі розвитку
українського суспільства модернізації
системи освіти введення нових освітніх
стандартів значно зростає роль вчителя
як активного суб'єкта педагогічного
процесу підвищуються вимоги до його
особистісних професійних якостей та
професійної позиції що і відображено у
концепції нової української школи Таким
чином на сьогодні ми говоримо про те
що
вчитель виконує нові соціально
професійні
ролі Він не є більше єдиним наставником
і джерелом знань він є коучем тютором
модератором в індивідуальній освітній
траєкторії кожної дитини тому що кожного
дня саме вчителі долають виклики
пов'язані із навчанням дітей під час
війни думають над тим як правильно
побудувати свою діяльність як працювати
з класом коли розриви між рівнем знань
дітей постійно збільшуються шукають і
віднаходять ті методи і прийоми навчання
що якнайкраще реалізуватимуть освітню
траєкторі кожної
дитини адже в основі всього має бути
дитиноцентризм на
Сьогодні дуже важливим є спілкування між
педагогами обмін досвідом
взаємопідтримка співпраця і це дійсно
прекрасно що на сьогодні існують
професійні спільноти вчителів Які
розвиваються набирають обертів у
середовищі яких кожен може вчити і
навчатися надихати і надихатися творити
новий контент для якісної взаємодії зі
своїм учнем та ділитися на працюваннями
із колегами взаємопідтримка та співпраця
в межах професійних спільнот допомагають
учителям у подоланні професійних
викликів учитель є і буде ключем до
якісної освіти зокрема і в умовах війни
тому
пані У пані і не пропав звук видно якісь
технічні
проблеми
зараз добре
А пані Іно Да У пані Іно технічній
проблеми на жаль їй не вдалося
завершити свою доповідь але я вже знаю
що вона була близька до цього і Щиро
дякуємо пані іні за те що вона окреслила
стан освіти в Україні зараз та ті
виклики які існують і Дійсно я тут хочу
доєднатися до тієї думки яку а озвучила
пані Інна що наразі спільноти вчителів
обмін досвідом
взаємопідтримка розуміння що не
тільки один або одна вчитель або
вчителька переживає те що зараз
відбувається і що всі ці виклики долають
інші
вчителі дуже важливо і тому ми
пропонуємо далі поглянути на одну з
можливостей подолання цих викликів а
саме на підтримку спільноти підтримка
від спільноти спільне навчання обмін
досвідом - Це ті можливості які можуть
додати натхнення та наснаги вчителям та
збагатити їх
ідеями як долучитися до професійних
спільнот Ви можете запитати яким чином
отримати підтримку та яким чином можна
поділитися своїм досвідом І зараз я вам
пропоную презентацію від наших партнерів
із save the children які розбудовують
мереж фізичних просторів які стають
осередками подібних спільнот офлайн і
про це детальніше від пана Олександра
голіка радника з питань цифрової освіти
пане Олександре вам
слово Дуже дякую пані Неля і взагалі
хочу подякувати за
запрошення Отже я як сказала пані Неля
Олександр мене звати Олександр я радник
з питань цифрової освіти та координатор
групи з питань цифрової трансформації
освітнього кластеру А зараз я пошарю
свій екран секундочку е так так так
повинно з'явитися
АА Отже
ее цифрові освітні центри або Digital
Learning Cent DLC я буду казати DLC як
стала на стала назва що це таке Ну це
цікава історія бо DLC вони задумувались
як
лише засоби доступу дітей до цифрової
освіти тобто як кімната з комп'ютерними
девайсами куди дитина може прийти і
безоплатно скористуватися цими девайсами
якщо вона не може це зробити з якихось
причин Вдома Або в школі але зараз DLC
почали трансформуватися причому Вони
почали трансформуватися самі Тобто це
вже живий проект це вже щось живий
організм який реагує на потреби і який
змінюється відповідно до цих потреб що я
маю на увазі зараз DLC стали стали так
би мовити центром тяжіння як це є школа
і я бачив багато прикладів під час
польових візитів коли вся все село всі
діти села майже вони біля DLC або вони
прекрасно знають Це DLC ють
фасилітаторів знають один одного Я бачу
приклади
як внутрішньо переміщені особи які з
якихось причин Можливо там погане знання
української мови на заході України вони
мали проблеми з тим щоб інтегруватися в
місцеві громади але вони йдуть DLC і
почувають себе там цілком комфортно Отже
зараз роль DLC значно ширша це не тільки
надання доступу до інтернету Та до
девайсів це психологічна підтримка це
безліч додаткових курсів та програм е в
тому числі там і комп'ютерні це it
грамотність і 3d-моделювання і
3d-принтери І все що завгодно Це
віртуальні подорожі я знаю під час
саммеркемпу вінтеркемпу віртуальні
подорожі Україною та світом українська
історія
громадянські права громадян України
це все
вивчається дітьми в
DLC також це дуже хороша база для чогось
нового цього в цьому році ми вже
фокусуємось на ми я маю на увазі всіх
партнерів які власне створюють DLC на
якості DLC та на розвитку програм які в
них використовуються Тобто це
спеціалізовані програми щодо
психоемоціна
емоціональної підтримки це програми з де
дитина є центром прийняття рішень
наприклад Safe schools да безпечні школи
це програми для молоді наприклад Life
Skills
[музика]
тобто Skills Ну не буду перекладати
життєві
скіли і багато інших однією
з етапів розвитку DLC яких зараз до речі
більше 140 було відкрито по всій Україні
за даними партнерів це DLC для вчителів
Це була так би мовити експериментальна
модальність був відкритий один Микола в
місті Миколаєві і ще один планується
відкрити в Миколаївській області Отже
його різниця в тому
що там нема фасилітаторів Є тільки
супервайзер і він запрошує розраховане
саме на вчителів тобто вчителі приходять
туди вони користуються цими девайсами
комп'ютерами для них проводяться
тренінги що щодо підвищення їх
професійного рівня і капаacті і
підтримку їх
психоемоційного розвитку там І взагалі
емоційна підтримка цих вчителів а
вчителі туди коли я був там з польовим
візитом приходили зі своїми класами
Тобто Це був вчитель і були діти був
клас цього вчителя і вони за мали
комп'ютери і вели звичайний урок як це
буває в школі і це навіть те що ми і не
могли подумати що так може бути але це
як я вже казав живий проект він
розвивається і ми повинні тільки
реагувати і підтримувати те що є Отже
DLC чогось такого тимчасового бо це було
задумано як тимчасови проект з чогось
такого дуже не не то що неофіційного
неформально неформального можливо
оскільки DLC не є школою і не має на
меті перебирання на себе функції школи
DLC стало чимось дійсно працюючим чимось
дійсно якимось таким місцем куди діти
дійсно хочуть іти і вони туди йдуть і це
є як я вже
казав чудовою точкою чудовою стартовою
лінією
для інших програм для розвитку та для
вдосконалиня
цього зараз іде кампанія щодо
обізнаності населення про DLC вона йде
як в інтернеті так і не в інтернеті за
допомогою плакатів які будуть
надруковані вже друкуються а і
також як я вже казав це
підтримка додаткових програм які будуть
імплементовані цього року в DLC
Отже в мене все стосовно DLC Я дуже
дякую організаторам ще раз і я хочу
окремо подякувати міністерству освіти та
науки за те що вони завжди підтримували
DLC і ми завжди відчували цю підтримку
та
кооперацію і дякую вам хочам за то що
вислухали мене Дякую щиро дякую пане
Олександре що
поділилися з нами інформацією про
цифрові освітні центри Я теж багато чула
про них я знаю що і вчителі і батьки які
і внутрішньо переміщені батьки з дітьми
долучаються до цих центрів і дійсно
спільноти шкіл і класів долучаються
взагалі знаю дуже багато чудових
проектів які реалізує організація Se The
chelden разом з партнерами і я думаю що
ті хто не чув до цього про цифрові
освітні центри підуть вже дивитися де ж
найближчий до того місця де вони
проживають Тому долучайтеся це дійсно
надзвичайні простори які допомагають
ділитися ідеями отримувати
підтримку і
будувати свої власні мережі всередині
цих центрів але на жаль уча війни та
невизначеності не всі вчителі можуть
приєднуватися до спільноти офлайн Тому
зараз пані Ольга мурасова експертка з
освіти Юнеско презентує вам важливість і
актуальність онлайн освіти для
професійного розвитку і трохи вже почне
привідкривати завісу на курс цифровий
вчитель Прошу пані Ольга вам
слово
Вітаю дійсно як зазначали Мої колеги
цифровізація є необхідністю сьогодення
що може допомогти і нашій стійкості але
й водночас ефективному навчанню втім
цифрова педагогіка як більшість вчителів
знають не є такою простою як здається на
перший погляд і насправді нерівнозначна
наявності цифрових інструментів на уроці
вона місти чимало прихованих викликів та
ризиків і саме тому курс цифровий
учитель було розроблено за участю
інституту освіти для миру та стійкості
махатмаганді Юнеско на основі
міжнародних досліджень а також Із
залученням українських експертів які
створили досвід навчання для українських
вчителів що відповідає викликам часу та
контексту цифрові технології створюють
безсумнівно нові можливості е-е ми
можемо забезпечувати свободу вибору
учням координувати індивідуальні
траєкторії навчання відстежувати прогрес
більш швидко та надавати вчасний
зворотний звяз зв'язок щоб досягнення
цифровізації слугували підвищенню
ефективності навчання фокусом уваги
педагогів зараз є універсальний дизайн
навчання нові підходи до оцінювання та
взаємодії з класом і це саме те що
створило і основу курсу цифровий учитель
Наприклад чи завжди цифрові технології в
освітньому процесі сприяють кращим
результатам учителі курсу мають
можливість ознайомитися з результатами
наукових досліджень що зазначають те що
лише цифровий контент та обладнання
насправді не є достатнім адже навчання
відбувається коли поєднується доступ до
технологій та ефективна присутність
вчителя підтримка учнів добре
сформульована модель навчання сприятливе
навчальне середовище а також актуальний
і привабливий контент складні теми
розкладаються у курсі на квести та кроки
якими рухаються слухачі курсу до мети
нового досвіду навчання у цифровому
світі наприклад залучення учнів виклик з
яким працює кожний вчитель незалежно від
предмету у курсі ми розглядаємо фактори
які сприяють такі залученні
інтерес до отримання досвіду підтримка
зусиль самоконтроль втім ми не
зупиняємося На цьому і йдемо до
стратегії які вчитель може застосувати
для забезпечення кожного з них за
результатами досліджень ефективності
технологій в освіті дизайн навчання - це
ключ тому універсальний дизайн став на
ріжним каменем курсу саме до цієї теми
ми отримуємо і найбільше запитань від
користувачів курсу а тому забезпечуємо
додаткову підтримку у спільноті про що
також будемо говорити Сьогодні далі до
того ж вчителі можуть помітити що курс
моделює сам по собі універсальний дизайн
на початку кожного квесту є цілі
зазначено можливі перешкоди інструменти
оцінювань а наприкінці рефлексія та
перевірка компетентностей Це ті поради з
курсу які стосуються і планування уроків
учителі курсу виконують практичні
завдання із застосуванням різних
цифрових інструментів наприклад на
слайді ви бачите як вчителі працюють над
розвіюванням міфу про середнього учня
якого насправді не існує але натомість
Вони спостерігають варіативність та
унікальність своїх учнів розробляючи
згодом стратегії для її для їхнього
врахування Під час планування уроку ми
Дуже радіємо що вже понад 40 4 5 000
вчителів навчаються на курсі ми бачимо
що серед слухачів всі регіони України та
вчителі з-за кордону втім Найбільша
частка саме там де відбувається
дистанційний навчальний процес і ми раді
що ми можемо надати там підтримку ми
бачимо слухачів курсу всіх вікових
категорій починаючи від студентів
педагогічних коледжів яким ще не
виповнилося 18 років так і до більш
досвідчених вчителів
за
результатами опитування ми знаємо що 98
вчите відсотків вчителів отримують
користь та нові знання після проходження
курсу незалежно від
того який був стартовий початок для
когось це систематизація знань а для
когось це новий підхід і опанування
абсолютно нової теми але дистанційний
курс як і дистанційна освіта по бує
зміни підходів успішність навчання
залежить від своєчасності зворотнього
зв'язку пропонування успішних прикладів
а також підтримки у спільноті можливості
задати питання поділитися висновками
враженнями і просто завжди разом
приємніше навчатися і зростати тому ми
не обмежилися лише курсом цифрової
учитель а побачили потребу у спільноті
яка б об'єднала вчителів Для успішного
провадження цифровізації підтримки
підтримки стійкості можливості разом
долати висновки Мої колеги далі
розкриють трішечки більше деталей Чим ви
можете збагатитися у спільноті сучасних
учителів втім я вже закликаю вас
долучатися як до курсу цифровий учитель
так і до спільноти сучасних учителів ми
будемо раді зростати разом з вами та
відкривати Нові горизонти цифровізації
дякую щиро дякую пані Ольга за те що
поділилися з нами трохи змістом курсу
цифровий учитель та його родзинками і я
тут доєднуюся абсолютно до вас що варто
переходити за цими
посиланнями варто реєструватися на курс
цифровий учитель якщо ви цього не робили
бо це дійсно корисно це дійсно актуально
і інноваційно а також доєднуватися до
спільноти сучасних учителів а як саме
такі онлайн-спільноти працюють які їх
унікальні особливості та вплив на
освітні галузі розкаже пані Аліна
коломійченко головна тренерка експертка
з освіти Юнеско учитель початкових
класів Чернігівської загальноосвітньої
школи першого ступеня номер 25 пані
Аліна вам слово Добрий день шановні
колеги Сьогодні я хочу поділитись з вами
унікальними практичними аспектами та
перевагами спільноти практиків онлайн
Чим же наші спільноти відрізняється від
подібних груп у
Фейсбуці наступне Як вже було сказано
курс цифровий учитель розрахований на
всіх учителів а спільнота має можливість
надавати підтримку вчителям у кожній з
освітніх галузей а також учителям
початкової школи та освітнім
управлінцям і це все можливо саме
завдяки нашим освітнім експертам які
завжди не просто діляться знаннями але й
надають практичні поради які є
незамінними для розвитку професійних
навичок кожного учителя вони створюють
міцну основу для нашої
спільноти вони надають чіткі інструкції
Та поради щодо різноманітних цифрових
інструментів Які можна використати у
кожній конкретній галузі наприклад на
цьому слайді ви бачите я як наша
тренерка з математичної освітньої галузі
надає чіткі інструкції про те які
інструменти можна використати саме для
математичної галузі вона показує
інструкцію як користуватися надає
візуаль
візуальний надає візуальну підтримку та
відповідає на питання якщо вони
виникають Але незважаючи на всю
доцільність та незамінність використання
цифрових інструментів не варто забувати
про те що живе спілкування не можна
недооцінювати адже вони адже воно
дозволяє нам обмінюватися досвідом
знаходити нові ідеї вирішувати проблеми
які виникають у нашій повсякденній
роботі наприклад на цьому слайді ви
бачите як наші тренери кожного дня
відповідають на десятки коментарів
надають інформацію щодо запитань та
просто підтримують наших
колег і це все призводить до того що
вчителі мають можливість впроваджувати
практичний досвід не боячись маючи змогу
маючи змогу поставити питання отримати
відповідь на нього або просто поговорити
з
однодумцями крім практичного досві крім
впровадження практичного досвіду наша
спільнота активно обговорює питання
пов'язані з курсом цифровий учитель це
включає тематичні пости від експертів
статті відповіді на коментарі та питання
а також вебінари це допомагає нам
підтримувати високий рівень знань та
залишатися в курсі останніх тенденцій у
сфері освіти також важливо додати що ми
тісно співпрацюємо будь ласка
поверніться назад також важливо додати
що ми тісно співпрацюємо з експертами
курсу які допомагають нам максимально
ефективно
впроваджувати та до впроваджувати його
досвід та допомагати учасникам його
проходити також учасники спільноти
можуть впливати на контент у групі адже
в нас налагоджена система збору та
впровадження зворотного зв'язку за
допомогою опитувальників серед учасників
групи збору відгуків та аналізу
коментарів наприклад на цьому слайді ви
можете побачити що під час одного з
опитувань е учасники дали нам зрозуміти
що для них дуже цікава тема електронних
навчальних платформ і це стало сигналом
для наших тренерів Наступного разу ширше
розкрити цю тему обговорити її Та по
подискутувати Ми також активно
обговорюємо виклики сьогодення Та
ділимося питаннями які виникають у нашій
щоденній роботі це допомагає нам
знаходити ефективні шляхи їх вирішення
та підтримувати один одного це такі
питання як
від як від того як говорити про
російсько-українську війну у школі Так і
до питань цифрової безпеки та
благополуччя адже це також дуже важливо
у наш час
і нарешті хочу згадати про наші конкурси
та призи Вони не тільки дарують
позитивний настрій але й спонукають до
обміну практичними наробками та ідеями
вчителі завжди дуже активно приймають
беруть участь у такій діяльності і дають
дуже дуже позитивні фідбеки і
підсумовуючи Я хочу сказати що курс
цифровий учитель та наша спільнота
практиків онлайн відіграють ключову роль
у розвитку сучасної освіти вони на дають
учителям необхідні ресурси підтримку та
спільноту для професійного зростання тож
я ще раз закликаю вас обов'язково
приєднуватись до нашої спільноти бути
там активними А якщо у вас виникли
будь-які питання будь ласка залишайте їх
у коментарях під цим відео ми
обов'язково надамо відповідь Дякую за
увагу дякую пані Аліна за те що
презентували нам спільноту за те що
показали що вчителі зможуть побачити
коли доєднаються до сторінки та групи
побачити який зміст там є і також задати
свої запитання які їх турбують А але
давайте зараз трошечки поглянемо
глибше і я
пропоную подивитися на спільноту
збоку управлінця та тренерки цієї
спільноти наступна наша спікерка пані
Світлана іванісова є фасилітаторкою
освітньої галузі освітні управнільців
спільноті сучасних учителів вона є
заступницею директора з освітнього
процесу запорізької гімназії номер 6
сертифікованим тренером нової
української школи авторкою навчальних
тренінгових програм для вчителів
інформатики та початкової школи пані
Світлана готова вже поділитися досвідом
що особисто їй даєця спільнота і яким
чином вона працює в цій спільноті як
фасилітаторка і як тренерка тож пані
Світлано дуже чекаємо
на ваш виступ прошу вам
слово дякую пані Неля з задоволенням
розповім школа - це різномані
різноманітний живий організм і одну із
функцій цього живого організму виконує
команда менеджерів освіти сучасний
заклад освіти може бути успішним лише
тоді коли на чолі станови стане
згуртована команда професіоналів яка
володіє новими технологіями навчання
виховання та менедж
менеджему освіти які ідеї будуть
пріоритетні в цій команді такою буде вся
діяльність закладу освіти це вже аксіома
менеджер освіти є і організатором і
контролером і координатором і як який
покликаний оперативно гасити пожежі які
виникають в педагогічному колективі а
також виконує роль двигуна сили якого
направлені на підтримку робочого ритму в
колективі в створенні позитивного
мікроклімату приємної і продуктивної
взаємодії всіх учасників освітнього
процесу саме тому я так вважаю дуже
важливо на сторінках посібника галузі
освітні управлінці розбирати питання які
допоможуть і вчителям і менеджерам
освіти використовувати ефективно цифрові
технології для того щоб зробити процес
навчання гнучким мотивованим та успішним
для кожного учня і Я запрошую вас колеги
до дієвої комунікації у спільноті
освітні управлінці де ми втілюємо
спільні задуми для світлого майбутнього
кожного і ко кожної в спільноті
практиків є унікальна нагода
презентувати себе свої ідеї досвід
захоплюватися цікавими формами і
методами роботи креативних неординарних
колег ділитися аналізувати та
рефлексувати Отже якщо ви вчитель чи
менеджер освіти який готовий
використовувати фільтрувати оцінювати
проектувати та поширювати цифрові
освітні ресурси використовувати свій
особистий потенціал на повну потужність
то запрошуємо вас стати частиною нашої
спільноти я також хочу сказати вам про
те що життя мчить зі швидкістю вітра і
ми просто Не встигаємо озиратися та
усвідомлювати як швидко усе минає як
цінно і Інколи просто зупинитися на мить
і наслодитися тим що робимо Які
результати отримуємо кому можемо бути
корисним і яку користь світо світові
створюємо
найціннішим є середовище яке мотивує
думати
найзмістовнішим є події під час яких
Виникають нові запитання найважливішим є
люди котрі спонукають до появи
відповідей на твої запитання і все це
можна отримати в спільноті сучасний
вчитель аналізуючи коментарі колег та
опитування у спільноті я як
фасилітатор галузі освітнь управлінці З
натхненням провела практичний вебінар
для підвищення фахової майстерності
педагогів на тему інсайти продуктивності
педагога та створення цифрового
органайзера до цього вебінару в грудні
долучилось більше 100 вчителів та
управлінців які спробували розкрити
потенціал цифрового цифрових
інструментів для освіти також дізнались
про український сервіс для управління
знаннями думками та ідеями стайл
всі присутні На вебінарі а також ті
вчителі та управлінці які доєдналися до
нас і передивились запис вебінару в
нашій спільноті отримали подарунки
е це 20 цифрових просторів для вчителів
і управлінців які можна скопіювати та
редагувати під свій під свої потреби А
ті
учасники які були з нами онлайн могли
стати долучитися до вікторини і
переможці отримали 10 інклюзивних
промокодів для покупки Про версії
сервісу xyle
менеджер освіти - це не тільки посада а
певний рівень професіоналізму в
управління від професіоналізму директора
школи та управлінської команди багато
чого залежить успішні успіш сами
успішний розвиток освітнього закладу
його
конкурентнопроможність і авторитет
особисто для мене я можу сказати що
ее участь в
спільноті Мені дуже цікава ее дуже
цікаво спостерігати за всіма галузями
нашої спільноти читати цікаві статті
колег впроваджувати в практику цікаві
форми методу роботи дуже корисно саме
різноманітні спільноти І мені як
заступнику директора це дуже важливо
бачити все загалом і рекомендувати своїм
колегам ті напрямки які дуже цікаві і
актуальні і є трендами трендами в освіті
цифрова трансформація суспільства
створює нові умови для навчання у
постійно змішаному ландшафті освіти
цифрові інструменти стали невід'ємним
спільником як і для вчителів так і для
учнів вони не лише полегшують навчання
та виклада дання але
також відкривають захопливі можливості
та цифрові горизонти для інновацій та
залучення роблять уроки цікавішими та
ефективнішими е-е класифікація
програмних засобів для проектування
уроків здійснюється в системі
педагогічного ланцюжка це теорія
дослідження практика та контроль і тут
вчителю потрібно навчитися ретельно
обирати цифрові ресурси враховуючи
навчальні потреби і навички учнів а
також фактори пов'язані з особливостями
кожного інструменту і я впевнена що у
кожного вчителя є в своїй методичній
скарбничці різноманітні методи приємами
організації роботи зі школярами але якщо
вам цікаво відкрити чарівну скриньку з
нескінченним запасом креативних ідей з
використанням наприклад неймомереж
наступний
слайд або дізнатися відповідь на такі
питання у чому суперсила цифровового
пдагога та суперсила на просторах
інтернету чи потрібні в колективі
цифрові вчителі саме на ці питання можна
найти відповіді в спільноті сучасний
вчитель а також проходячи курс цифровий
вчитель і на останок
хочу декілька слів сказати про таку
важливу тему наступний слайд як
унікальний дизайн навчання е концепція
універсального дизайну виникла ще в 70-х
роках А ми все й досі не зовсім
розуміємо принципи універсальноного
дизайну навчання деякі вчителі вважають
це
синонімом інклю інклюзивного навчання
але це не так курс цифровий вчитель
допоміг саме мені детальніше розібратися
в цій темі і я занурилась у курс і
дізналась як оцінювати учнів еффективно
та за принципами удн як краще ефектно чи
ефективно чому важливо враховувати
принципи он під час
оцінювання я опрацювала дєви методи
оцінювання такі як мішень метод графіка
побажання вчителю метод угода метод
небо метод письмово есе і дуже багато
інших а ще й додала до своєї професійної
скарбнички ще дієві методи оцінюваєня
якими поділилися колеги в спільноті тому
що після кожного квесту у нас в
спільноті є дошка для взаємодії падли на
якої ми можемо ділитися думками і зараз
маючи таку нагоду хочу подякувати
професійним креативним неординарним
цікавим
цілеспрямованим менеджерам освіти та
вчителям які долучились до спільноти
освітні управлінці а також всій команді
курсу цифрового вчителя та
спільноті сучасного вчителя Запрошуємо і
вас колеги до дієвої комунікації Дякую
за
увагу Так дякую пані Світлано що
поділилися вже своїм досвідом і
відгуками про те як ви користуєтеся в
своїй
діяльності знаннями з курс і знаннями і
тими навичками Які ви отримали в курсі
цифровий вчитель а також яким чином
збагачуєте свій досвід та черпаєте ідеї
для
уроків в спільноті зараз я би хотіла
передати слово пані Галині лаврин
яка розкриє нам дуже
незвичну незвичне питання Як пов'язана
фізкультурнаосвітня галузь та цифрові
технології коли ми думаємо про фізичне
виховання інколи думаємо фізичне
виховання і цифрові технології яким
чином вони можуть бути разом але пані
Галина точно знає відповідь на це
запитання і якщо ви не бачили вебінар
пані Галини в спільноті сучасних
вчителів Я вам дуже раджу під і
подивитися тому що ви там точно знаєте
надзвичайно велику кількість
ідей яким чином можна застосувати
цифрові технології а в
фізкультурно-освітній галузі
тож пані Галина
Лаврін фасилітатор даної галузі кандидат
наук з фізичного виховання та спорту
доцент Тернопільського національного
педагогічного університету імені
Володимира Гнатюка пані Галина вам
слово Вітаю Шановні колеги та гості
захду Дозвольте мені сьогодні з вами
поділитися можливостями та доцільністю
використання цифрових інструментів у
галузі фізичної культури а також
їх втілення у навчальний процес чому
саме фізкультурнаосвітня галузь тому що
дану галузь найчастіше оминають
недостатньо висвітлюють уникають
впровадження цифрових інструментів та
їхніх можливостей у підвищення
ефективності навчального-тренувального
процесу втім вчителі фізичної культури
заслуговують на меншої підтримки
можливості професійного ро розвитку та
доступу до цифрових
технологій саме у спільноті сучасних
вчителів ухоплені всі галузі серед яких
чиінне місце належить
фізкультурно-освітні галузі гостра
проблема у створенні Такої спільноти
такої освітньої галузі виникла в нас ще
у період ковіду коли вчителям усім
довелося терміново перейти на
дистанційний формат навчання якщо іншим
вчителям з інших предметів таких і
біологія хімія і так дальше достатньо
було на початкових етапах здійснити
зустріч на різних онлайн платформах і
переходити до пояснення чи опитування
навчального матеріалу на початкових
етапах звісно бо цифрові інструменти
вдосконалювалися пізніше вже вони
використовувались на багато сучасніші
інноваційніші але в нас на початкових
етапах ми не знали як це зробити як
одночасно вчителю фізичної культури
забезпечувати і рухову діяльність і
слідкувати за діями учнів на уроках як
адаптувати інвентар з фізичної культури
до домашніх умов наприклад е палиця
гімнастична в домашніх умовах могла
стати палицею від швабри а м'ячик для
метання перетворювався у м'ячик
створений із шкарпеток ці та багато до
інших ідей наші вчителі які творчо
підходили до цих процесів зуміли
е зуміли вийти з цього положенні але
оскільки таких спільнот не було якщо
Один хтось міг придумати якусь нову ідею
її демонструвати для інших не було де і
ця проблема в нас була до створення
Такої спільноти яка зараз нас полегшує і
створює ефективні умови для ділення
досвідом е Наприклад ми бачимо на слайді
одне з моїх занять де ми з нашими учнями
пробували грати шашки на урок заняття
досить просте в організації але його
сама
підготовка потребувала інвестицій багато
часу оскільки потрібно було визначити
яка платформа є корисна яка є доступна
яка не потребує
реєстрації для гри шашок з учнями на
якій платформі можна запрошувати учень
один одного а не тільки серед
запропонованих учасників цієї платформи
окрім того як організувати Цей урок як
забезпечити щоб учні бачили хто з ким
грає і так дальшето багато багато
моментів але коли один раз розібравшись
них можна вже ділитися досвідом і багато
вчителів скориставшись такими ідеями
легко впроваджували у навчальний процес
е-е ми бачимо на слайді е один із
вебінарів який ми провели у своїй
спільноті тема якого організація і
проведення спортивних змагань з
використанням з використанням цифових
інструментів і на цьому на цьому
вебінарі було вчителям запро
запропоновано один огляд кількох
цифрових інструментів одним з яких був
як замінити Як удосконалити цей процес
організації змагань і замінити всю цю
рутинну роботу вчителя тренера
організатора змагань одним цифховим
додатком і схвальні відгуки коментарі на
цей вебінар заохочу хочуть працювати
дальше в цій спільноті і ділитися
досвідом один з одним і впроваджувати
такі цифрові
інструмент Слід відмітити що
цифровізація не зводиться до проведення
занять онлайн це і втілення нових
інструментів для підготовки та
організації навчального чи тренувального
процесу Проте зараз ми вже стоїмо на
сходинку вище ж правда В нас же є
спільнота де ми публікуємо дописи
організовуємо вебінари коментуємо
ділимося своїм досвідом і також вчителі
мають і тренери мають можливість
задавати ідеї та пропозиції які доцільно
було б висвітлювати у нашій спільноті ще
однією особливості даної спільноти є те
що в нас одночасно є галузі з усіх
навчальних предметів і ее освітяни які
цікавляться одним напрямком вони
слідкують за дописами в своїй галузі
водночас вони можуть бачити які яка
інформація подається в інших галузях і
таким чином скористатися трансформувати
всі ці нові сучасні інструменти в свою
галузь і таким чином підвищувати свій
навчальний тренувальний процес якщо
когось цікавить культурно-освітня галузь
щиро Запрошуємо в нашу
спільноту ділитися обмінюватися і
отримувати цікавий досвід в організації
проведення занять з використанням
свтових інструментів коротко це все
Дякую за увагу щиро дякую пані Галино
власне дійсно ви почули як вже багато є
інформації яка розміщена в
спільноті також хочу вас ще раз
повернути до того вебінару який вже
проведений пані Галиною а а також хочу
зазначити що зараз ви почули досвід двох
фасилітаторок цієї спільноти про те
спільнота закриває всі галузі тому якщо
ви не почули інфор іформацію про свою
галузь Заходьте дивіться шукайте
посібник своєї галузі і збагачуйтеся
ідеями крім цього у спільноті
розкривається також психологічне
психологічний аспект навчання і
викладання і ним опікуюся я Неля Лебідь
експертка Юнеско з ментального здоров'я
та психосоціальної підтримки кандидатка
психологічних наук доцентка і
співавторка модельної програми та
підручників курсу культури сусідства для
учнів п'ятих-шостих класів нової
української школи тож зараз про
продовжуємо говорити про спільноту
сучасних учителів і я пропоную вам
поглянути на неї як на ресурс для
збереження ментального здоров'я та
можливості отримати психосоціальну
підтримку ні в кого зараз не виникає
запитань чому психосоціальна підтримка
та збереження ментального здоров'я
важливі вчителі і до війни були в зоні
ризику більш значного емоційного
вигорання як представники професії
людина-людина зараз цей ризик зріс через
довготривалий хронічний стрес який
пов'язаний з війною і саме тому
профілактика та збереження ментального
здоров'я стають критичними для
ефективного функціонування в професії
дуже багато організацій займаються цими
цими питаннями зараз але це й накраще
тому що є
можливість отримати допомогу Тож давайте
зараз подумаємо чому перебування в
спільноті допомагає людині зберігати
ментальне здоров'я Звісно якщо за умови
ця звісно за умови якщо ця спільнота є
конструктивною і взаємодія в ній не
містить ознак
насилля це може здатися на перший погляд
простим запитанням бо ви можете мені
сказа сказати що людина соціальна істота
і бути серед людей одна з її потреб та
можливостей для зростання і розвитку Але
пропоную вам все-таки поглянути на це
трохи глибше і зрозуміти що ж може дати
освітянам спільнота сучасних
учителів спільнота сучасних учителів
об'єднує в собі
освітян тобто її учасники та учасниці
мають спільну Іден ність всі вони різні
з різних регіонів різних закладів освіти
різних галузей але всі вони долають
виклики сьогодення шукають шляхи
розвитку та намагаються адаптуватися до
нової реальності їх об'єднує розуміння
важливості використання цифрових
технологій і прагнення навчитися робити
це
ефективно крім цього спільнота дає
відчуття приналежності в ній ви може
можете знайти своїх бути серед своїх в
спільноті можна знайти людей зі
спільними цінностями і переконаннями а
також в безпечному просторі почути іншу
точку зору
подискутувати спробувати зрозуміти що
стоїть за точкою
зору іншої людини і як я вже сказала для
того щоб кожен був почутий і міг
висловитися важливо ось саме мати Цей
безпечний пру простір як вже зазначали
наші попередні доповідачі спільнота має
фасилітаторів і модераторів які є
експертами своєї галузі їх завдання
підтримувати комунікацію надавати
роз'яснення слідкувати за коментарями і
це не означає що відбувається фільтрація
думок в спільноту потрапляють тільки
потрібні коментарі точно ні завдання
модераторів слідкувати за тим щоб діалог
був конструктивним та змістовним і
залиша залишався в площині питань
обговорення а не переходив на
особистості Крім того в спільноті
сучасних учителів є можливість
обмінюватися інформацією та ідеями
швидше та ефективніше знаходити рішення
знаходити партнерів та будувати власні
мережі і так та ця спільнота була
створена штучно ви можете сказати що ну
ви ж її створили але і точкою входу
дійсно був курс цифровий учитель проте
вона спроєктована таким чином що кожен
учасник та учасниця може бути активним
та активною запропонувати Свою тему для
обговорення задати запитання і бути
почутим Ми прагнемо щоб ця спільнота
ставала живою і щоб наповнювалася
відповідями на реальні запити та потреби
її учасників та учасник
Тепер давайте трохи поглянемо глибше на
зміст спільноти ви вже бачите цей слайд
і подивимося як Він сприяє збереженню
ментального здоров'я та реалізації
соціальної підтримки та психосоціальної
зокрема коли ми говоримо про подолання
життєвих ситуацій однією з найбільш
ефективних стратегій подолання буде саме
пошук соціальної підтримки і Дана
стратегія передбачає готовність
розділити з іншими свою проблему
попросити та отримати допомогу а тому
зараз пропоную розгляда розглядати
підтримку в більш широкому змісті ніж
тільки психосоціальна
ее як Вчителі можуть реалізувати власну
стратегію пошуку соціальної підтримки
через спільноту Це можливо завдяки ось
цим чотирьом видам підтримки
представленим в спільноті які ви бачите
зараз на слайді інформаційна
інструментальна емоційна та підтримка
групи я не буду детально їх коментувати
ви
можете прочитати зміст слайду
проте зупинюся на декількох важливих
моментах так в межах інформаційної
підтримки передбачено не тільки надання
інформаційних матеріалів а й проведення
вебінарів з цифрових технологій в освіті
та з психології вже зараз ви можете
знайти в да Зайти в гру
спільноту знайти дайджест вебінарів та
переглянути запис вебінарів які
відбулися наприклад вебінар щодо
практики турпоти про себе з аналізом
техніки емоційного регулювання
реалізації принципів травмоінформованого
навчального середовища створення
цифрового органайзеру та багато інших
тож запрошуємо вас до перегляду минулих
вебірарів та реєстрації на майбутнє які
ви вже Можете знайти в спільноті
також хочу вам анонсувати нову рубрику в
спільноті час чат з експертами учасники
спільноти можуть залишити запитання яке
їх турбує в Google формі і експерт
найбільш компетентний в ньому надасть
відповідь через пост в групі ми
передбачаємо формат як анонімних
запитань якщо ви не
хочете зазначати своє прізвище ім'я так
із зазначенням прізвищеам ім'я за
бажанням людини тож переходьте в групу
заповнюйте форму будемо разом робити
спільноту живою та актуальною до Запитів
сьогодення і о на останок крім цього в
межах курсу реалізовує курсу цифровий
вчитель реалізовується модуль
соціально-емоційне навчання де Вчителі
можуть ознайомитися зі змістом цього
напряму викладанні зрозуміти як
реалізовувати його на уроці визначити як
діяти в стресових та конфліктних
ситуаціях а спільно та в свою чергу дає
можливість уточнити поділитися досвідом
збагатитися ідеями колег в цьому напрямі
тож я щиро дякую вам що ви були з нами
Дякую вам за увагу Запрошуємо
приєднуватися до спільноти сучасних
учителів Запрошуємо проходити курс
цифровий вчи учитель Ця команда яка
працює працювала над курсом і зараз
працює над спільно
буде намагатися робити її максимально
актуальною і
максимально корисною для вас і тому
тут ваша участь є дуже важливою як я вже
говорила Давайте зробимо цю спільноту
живою Давайте зробимо її корисною і
наповнимо її важливим змістом і хочу
сказати на
останок дуже важливий момент що якщо ви
зайдете в спільноту ви вже побачите що
Ми перетнули 10 000 межу в 10 000
учасників тож вже на
людей у вас є можливість та запитати
щось і почути їх ідеї доєднуйтеся Ми
будемо дуже раді і як вже я зазначала на
початку якщо у вас виникли якісь думки
коментарі будь ласка залишайте їх під
цим відео ми обов'язково їх
проаналізуємо і надамо максимальну
змістовну відповідь Дякуємо що були з
нами Бережіть себе
а бережіть своє психічне ментальне
здоров'я і знаємо як багато ви зараз
робите І
дійсно вчителі важли як би там не було
вчителі важливі
тож робимо свою роботу Дякуємо і до
побачення